and speaking of illegal immigration
suddenly there are democrats pretending
to care about the border now eight of
them have been warning biden about
repealing title 42. remember that's the
trump era policy that allowed for
immediate turnbacks of illegals at the
border because of coven
now this list of senators includes four
who are up for reelection this fall
wouldn't you know it in hotly contested
races now none of them until recently
none of them were strong advocates for
border security or none of them of
course were against biden's handling of
it i'm talking about arizona's mark
kelly new hampshire's maggie hassan
george's raphael warnock and nevada's
catherine cortez masto all of them
disasters on the border so just don't be
fooled by any of this
if they end up getting re-elected
they'd be more than happy to continue
the destructive policies that biden has
been pushing on this country that
allowed two million illegals to pour
across our southern border since he took
office
which leads me to what i have been
saying for months
biden and his dhs secretary should be
impeached for the crime of conspiring to
keep the southern border open during a
national health emergency the house
could actually bring up a serious
perhaps impeachment inquiry just on this
issue of the border alone they impeached
a president for russia collusion yeah
and why isn't this border collusion at
some point
when the president conspires to subvert
the sovereignty of his own country
how could that not be ground through
impeachment now as you can see that's
what i've contended for some time now so
i was so pleased to see the argument
built out by charlie hurt in the
washington times writing he's aided and
comforted our foreign enemies by
publicly inviting illegals to swarm into
the country
he has purposefully undermined the
constitution he swore to uphold and
defend it's just that simple
charlie hurt washington times opinion
editor and fox news contributor joins me
now charlie now you go on to say that
president biden
isn't finished and that
on that only strengthens the argument
to start threatening this now explain
that
yeah well i you know it with the the
decision by the administration to lift
this title 42
you know you talk to border patrol
agents and they will tell you
that they're expecting a surge at the
border this summer that could top 250
000
illegals each
month which would be which would be
obviously a
historic invasion at the border
but i think the the biggest reason why
it's so important for republicans to
begin talking about this now is they
should talk about it before the election
they should make the election about this
issue so that when they win in november
they will have a greater mandate an
important mandate i mean american lives
are at stake human carnage fentanyl drug
overdoses by the tens of thousands i
mean we we have our own scenes of
desperation in this country
because our
a president and commander-in-chief
refuses
to do what he is constitutionally
obligated to
uh and and you hit the nail on the head
in this piece now charlie i got to say
here's how the administration responded
when peter ducey exposed how bad the
crisis is going to be watch
the department gave reporters an
estimate that up to eighteen thousand
migrants could be apprehended at the
border each day if title forty two were
fighting
and we'll see what happens and obviously
we're taking steps to convey that this
is not the time to come
charlie surely the migrants will respect
jen saki telling them that now is not a
great time to come i'm sure that'll make
them turn around on moss
right and what's even more absurd about
this is the fact that she could say that
if she wants but
the truth is and and you've reported
this all along migrants south of the
border they're watching the news they
know that president
biden
has turned on a welcome light to draw
all of them to the country and they are
even aware of this issue with title 42
they are poised to come into this
country and they know that they will get
away with it and they know that they
will be welcomed but this is the thing
and and you've understood this forever i
know this
this is an issue that is not just a
republican issue this is an issue that
matters to republican voters but also to
democrat voters and as donald trump
proved to politicians in washington it
also matters to hispanic voters for
example who want to have a secure border
everybody wants to have a secure border
it's not a controversial issue now
charlie the dea is warning local police
about another crisis spurred by the
border saying in just the past two
months
there have been at least seven confirmed
mass overdose events across the united
states resulting in 58 overdoses
29 overdose deaths tragic events like
these are being driven by fentanyl and
the fentanyl charlie as you've written
about
is coming from china through south of
the border
into the veins and into the bodies of
people across this country many of them
desperate whether they're out of work or
mental health or a combination or they
just get their drugs spiked
uh and it's it's mass carnage i'm just
going to keep saying it
yeah and you know if you talk to regular
people around the country i don't know
anyone who doesn't know someone who has
been affected by this uh this poison
that is pouring into our country that
you you either people in their own
family or people that they know have
been poisoned by this stuff and if this
was if this was a you know if this was a
a a smokestack that was billowing this
kind of poison that was killing this
a number of people
and especially young people in this
country um there would be there would be
a human cry it would be a problem that
would be fixed instantly charlie thank
you for this piece thank you for writing
this and
we'll have you back on this soon thank
you hey sean hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else